2017 has already produced a ton of Hollywood
hits, like Disney's live-action version of
Beauty and the Beast, DC's long-awaited solo
pic for Wonder Woman, and Jordan Peele's sensational
breakout thriller Get Out.
And it looks like the silver screen surprises
for this year aren't done just yet.
Whether you're into action, comedy, horror,
or drama, there are plenty of forthcoming
films that'll be fighting for your movie ticket
money over the next several months.
IT
The 1990 TV miniseries adaptation of Stephen
King's IT amassed a cult following.
But unfortunately, the four-hour feature's
laughable special effects and disorienting
cutaways haven't aged well.
Tim Curry's original performance as the town-terrorizing
clown Pennywise still set a high bar for anyone
to follow in the role, though.
So, when the new version of the character,
played by Bill Skarsgård, was first revealed
in a costume that could've easily been borrowed
from a schoolgirl's dress-up chest, it's only
natural that the movie faced a little blowback.
But everything we've seen of IT since then
has been absolutely bone-chilling, and gives
King fans reason to believe the new it-eration
will be floating atop the box office when
this movie lands on September 8th.
Kingsman: The Golden Circle
The creative team behind 2015's Kingsman:
The Secret Service reunites for this sequel,
which features the British spy team partnering
up with their American equivalents after their
headquarters are destroyed by a lethal foe.
"It's very American."
"Heh, yeah it is."
Original cast members like Taron Egerton and
Colin Firth are joined by an eclectic ensemble
that includes Channing Tatum, Halle Berry,
Julianne Moore, and Jeff Bridges for another
round of zany action.
The Golden Circle hits theaters on September
22nd.
"Time is running out."
Mother!
Director Darren Aronofsky has danced with
darkness in his films before, but with Mother!
he's going all-in on the horror genre at last.
The film features Jennifer Lawrence and Javier
Bardem as a couple who seem sublime — until
a bunch of unexpected house guests turn up
and all hell breaks loose.
While the surreal trailer doesn't give much
away, we do know it'll feature bleeding walls
and mobs with torches — and Lawrence screaming
her heart out.
And with Aronofsky behind the lens, it's bound
to be creepy and emotionally disorienting.
September 15th can't get here soon enough.
The LEGO Ninjago Movie
Yes, The LEGO Ninjago Movie is a feature-length
toy commercial.
But its predecessors have managed to be pretty
swell, so we can probably expect some of the
same animated awesomeness in this one, too.
In the movie, Dave Franco's character Lloyd
sets off to stop his supervillain father Garmadon
and teams up with fellow ninjas and a master
martial artist, voiced by none other than
Jackie Chan himself.
"I mean my mom is weird and collects seashells.
Your dad levels cities and attacks innocent
people.
So, they've all got their quirks you know?"
So get ready for another trip to LEGO land
this September 29th.
American Made
It's been a few decades since we last saw
Tom Cruise take the yoke of an airplane, but
before he becomes Maverick again for Top Gun
2, this time he's hitting the air as a bored
commercial pilot who becomes one of the world's
most notorious drug smugglers.
From the looks of it, when you're working
with the CIA, the DEA, and Pablo Escobar's
drug cartel all at once, there's a pretty
good chance things will go sideways.
Count on this one to take flight on September
29th.
Flatliners
If Flatliners sounds familiar, there's good
reason.
This upcoming sci-fi thriller is actually
a sequel to a 1990 Kiefer Sutherland vehicle
of the same name.
Like the original, Flatliners features a group
of five medical students who undergo near-death
experiences in an effort to document what
happens in the afterlife.
When they return, they have brand new abilities
and insights — and might be going a little
bit crazy.
The new Flatliners comes across as more of
a traditional horror film than its predecessor,
but if it's half as eerie as it looks, it
should make the already-dense September 29th
release date slate even more competitive.
Blade Runner 2049
Following up a towering sci-fi classic like
Blade Runner is a daunting task to the say
the least.
But Blade Runner 2049 director Denis Villeneuve
has a few big things going for him.
For one, Ridley Scott serves as producer on
the project, and Harrison Ford reprises his
role as Rick Deckard.
Ford's also joined by an ensemble rounded
out by Ryan Gosling, Robin Wright, Jared Leto,
and Dave Bautista.
"What do you want?"
"I want to ask you some questions."
Whether the end result can measure up to the
original remains to be seen, but if they can
pull it off, Blade Runner 2049 could make
one helluva movie experience come October
6th.
The Mountain Between Us
It's only a matter of time before Idris Elba
takes his rightful place as one of Hollywood's
top stars, and The Mountain Between Us might
be just the vehicle he needs.
In the film, he stars opposite Kate Winslet
in a landscape set amid hundreds of miles
of a barren, snowy wilderness, and the two
must team up to escape after surviving a plane
crash.
It might sound a little formulaic, but we
can probably count on these two powerhouses
to deliver some chilling performances when
this pic crashes into theaters on October
6th.
The Foreigner
This Jackie-Chan driven action flick features
the kung fu legend alongside Pierce Brosnan
reuniting with GoldenEye director Martin Campbell.
The pic features Chan as the father of a young
woman who's killed in a terrorist attack,
launching him into revenge mode.
In the process, he runs afoul of Brosnan's
character, a British government official who
has ties to the IRA — and who might hold
the key to uncovering the attackers' identities.
Between Chan's killer training and Brosnan's
debonair style, The Foreigner should make
for one exhilarating game of cat and mouse
when it hits theaters October 13th.
Happy Death Day
It isn't Friday the 13th in America if there
isn't a schlocky horror film in theaters,
and this year, it's Happy Death Day.
It's basically Groundhog's Day meets Scream,
as the film features a college student who
has to relive the day of her death over and
over again until she figures out who's killing
her.
If nothing else, it looks to be good for a
few fun jump scares and creative death scenes.
The Snowman
If campy horror isn't your preferred brand
of thrills, The Snowman might be what you're
looking for instead.
The film follows a couple of detectives trying
to track down a serial killer who leaves icy
little clues to toy with his investigators
in a sleepy Swedish snowscape.
With an all-star cast that includes Michael
Fassbender, Chloe Sevigny, and J.K. Simmons,
we can expect The Snowman to be absolutely
bone-chilling once it hits theaters on October
20th.
Professor Marston & the Wonder Women
If you haven't had enough of Wonder Woman
yet this year, give this origin story a try.
Professor Marston will give cinematic life
to the real-life man responsible for Diana
Prince, William Moulton Marston.
And if you don't already know anything about
the author, let's just say he had some interesting
views on male-female relationships.
"A person is most happy when they are submissive
to a loving authority."
You'll learn all about it if you check out
this pic on October 27th.
Jigsaw
Lionsgate was definitely playing a game by
presenting 2010's Saw 3D: The Final Chapter
as the very last round of Jigsaw's punishing
plans.
In the newest round of torture trials, a copycat
killer appears to be reviving John Kramer's
work in ways that are a little too on the
nose for the investigators tailing this new
villain.
Just like the other pictures that preceded
it, Jigsaw looks to be chock full of psychological
and physical horrors that'll test your tolerance
for gore when this thing hits theaters on
October 27th.
Suburbicon
George Clooney and the Coen brothers have
already proven themselves to be an interesting
filmmaking match thanks to O Brother, Where
Art Thou? and Hail, Caesar!
And now the three have teamed up again — with
the Coens writing and Clooney directing — to
bring this quirky crime thriller to theaters
next.
Suburbicon stars Matt Damon as a man who loses
his wife in a shocking home invasion incident
and watches as his idyllic little town turns
into a haven for deceit and darkness.
As with any Clooney-Coen collaboration, this
grim landscape will be peppered with plenty
of comedy, making it a must-see on October
27th.
Thor: Ragnarok
In Norse mythology, Ragnarök is an apocalyptic
series of events that results in the world
being plunged into water after the deaths
of several gods — including Odin, Thor,
and Loki — and culminates in a planetary
rebirth.
So, it's obvious from the title that this
chapter won't be a jolly good time for our
hammer-wielding hero.
"You have no idea."
The good news is, his imminent participation
in the upcoming Avengers: Infinity War means
he'll probably emerge from this adventure
relatively unscathed.
But before that, he'll have to break out of
prison — without his hammer — and play
gladiator opposite none other than The Incredible
Hulk.
So, we can definitely count on this to be
a marvelous new adventure for our Avenger
friends when it busts into theaters on November
3rd.
"Surprise!
This is going to be such fun."
Daddy's Home 2
The first Daddy's Home didn't exactly thrill
critics, but audiences ate it up.
So, in true sequel fashion, Daddy's Home 2
is doubling down on everything that made the
first movie stand out — including twice
as many dads as the original.
This time around, returning stars Will Ferrell
and Mark Wahlberg are joined by John Lithgow
and Mel Gibson as their respective fathers.
Naturally, chaos ensues once this quartet
gets together, so prepare for some major dad
jokes when this family comedy hits theaters
on November 10th.
Justice League
As DC's biggest, boldest attempt at a shared
universe outing, Justice League will pull
together its all-star superhero squad of Wonder
Woman, Batman, Aquaman, The Flash, and Cyborg,
as they tangle with the latest villains to
threaten the Earth.
If the massive receipts on Wonder Woman are
any indication, November 17th will be a big
day for the DC Extended Universe when this
superhero smash pic lands in theaters.
"They said the age of heroes would never come
again."
"It has to."
Coco
As Pixar's first non-sequel since The Good
Dinosaur, Coco tells the story of a young
boy named Miguel whose family has banned music.
His love of instruments leads him to the Land
of the Dead, where he teams up with a trickster
named Hector to unravel his family's history
across both planes of existence.
Count on this Pixar pic to make a splash when
it bows into cinemas on November 22nd.
The Disaster Artist
Tommy Wiseau's The Room is known for being
the single worst movie ever made, and James
Franco's The Disaster Artist aims to humorously
explore how such a terrible picture ever made
it to production in the first place.
Unlike its source material, The Disaster Artist
is actually expected to be good, and will
be a must-see for any movie fan when it lands
on December 8th.
The Shape of Water
Guillermo del Toro has got a way with movie
monsters, and The Shape of Water looks to
be an especially beastly treat.
The film stars Sally Hawkins, Michael Shannon
and Octavia Spencer, as it follows a disabled
janitor making pals with a water creature
that's tucked away in a secret research tank.
With all the eerie atmosphere and authority
of del Toro's distinct eye behind this film,
consider your calendar space for December
8th already booked.
Ferdinand
In this animated pic, John Cena stars as the
pacifist animated bull Ferdinand, who must
escape captivity to live his life of nonviolence
and merriment away from all the rodeos.
The film is based on the classic children's
book by Munro Leaf and Robert Lawson.
Ferdinand will be a family favorite when it
drops just in time for holiday break from
school on December 15th.
Jumanji: Welcome to the Jungle
Welcome to the Jungle is expected to recapture
the magic of the 1995 adventure film Jumanji.
But this time it features the Rock alongside
Jack Black, Karen Gillan, and Kevin Hart as
the players' avatars.
And instead of rolling dice, the characters
will be playing a videogame that sucks its
heroes into a fictional jungle.
They'll have to fight their way to the exit
if they want to win … or at least live.
"Damn that is a man right there."
"Don't cry, don't cry, don't cry, it's going
to be okay."
Pitch Perfect 3
If you thought the first two Pitch Perfect
movies were awesome, you're in for a treat
as the Bellas re-team for another round of
melodious shenanigans.
This time, the Barden ladies will be performing
at a USO show, where they'll compete with
bands using real instruments for the first
time.
So, prepare your pipes to sing right along
with your favorites when Pitch Perfect 3 harmonizes
with the holidays on its December 22nd release.
"Let's aca-finish this."
Star Wars: Episode VIII — The Last Jedi
After the success of The Force Awakens, the
new generation of Star Wars is coming back,
with Daisy Ridley, John Boyega and Oscar Isaac
all returning to the big screen in this new
chapter.
But what we don't know is what will happen
to the rest of the originals, especially in
the wake of Carrie Fisher's tragic and unexpected
death in 2016.
The title of this installment seems to mean
that Luke Skywalker is the last of his kind,
as the Resistance squares off against the
First Order, Snoke, and Kylo Ren.
Count on the box office force to be with Episode
8 when it hits theaters on December 15th.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!